hey guys I'm back sorry for not
uploading for a week this video has
really been my main focus this week so
sorry about that
but today's video is gonna be something
new and I thought I would explain it
it's basically a compilation of my
awesome and funny moments of me and my
buddy max playing the campaign
unrealistic so I thought I'd share that
with you guys
we've referred for lots of cringe it was
really late at night when we recorded
these be the way new video on Thursdays
would be prepared for that and with that
guys look the video you did enjoy
subscribe if you're new and comment your
opinions and if it's well received I
will gladly do some more of these anyway
hope you guys have a great rest of your
day and peace out enjoy the video
[Laughter]
come on come on the kid bye-bye what
time is it this is a bad oh oh yeah I
forgot about that I was like how long
waiting for you to skip yeah I see you I
see you and then it's just like
[Music]
not moving
oh I just killed
fight me dumbest [ __ ] ever yeah you can
do that in multiplayer Dominion stuff oh
my god I started I started doing it just
for jokes where did he go oh all right
where did he go he came out of my hands
what happened he went into the corner I
just got it I just got a comment on my
video saying Ubisoft or Cox Jesus
well what's up family this is max tech
Turner you're talking do and Farrell
hopefully Farrell did not pause the
audio recording is it's gonna be a
little one-on-one thing me and you you
guys wallah
gingy go fits the his bagels he wants so
uh this is actually like crazy because I
mean I never thought Farrell was gonna
get anywhere in life
and you guys are awesome I I look at
your comment section with Farrell's
videos and [ __ ] all the time it's it's
funny because it's like like for honor
is a very old to me at least is a very
toxic place is in like I I get bitched
out a lot in this game but everyone in
the comment section [ __ ] they are so
chill and it's just awesome and you guys
are awesome here toy your friends tell
your mom's friends tell your dad's
friends or if you don't have a dad like
me and gingi we don't have dads
because you know is a little self
masturbation thing they kill themselves
and [ __ ] someone I don't know it was
something like that
but tell them the watcher watch Farrell
he's awesome
he's funny as [ __ ] and then maybe you
will see more of me too
I'm an idiot but you know whatever
alright
[Music]
[Music]
they do me a favor
shoot me hmm and probably I'm pretty
sure goes to building that work was
[ __ ] awesome
you are in the stoned everybody the
black stone who go kyo it's it's like a
go-gurt flavor how is that a go-gurt
flavor yogurt flavors on like cranberry
and watermelon not Fujio kyo throw a
javelin you're gonna knock that off look
any slides rock you should have kicked
them down dude look at that squat what
the [ __ ] was that
[Music]
so
what did they tell you
well I don't speak Japanese
[Music]
yo first try baby let's go [ __ ] you do
it didn't I say we get this [ __ ] done by
2:30 maybe first try
[ __ ] you